Alhamdulillah.
Continuing
in
authored by
in the chapter of patience and says,
"And Allah the most high has also said
that which translates to and seek aid in
patience and prayer. Indeed, Allah is
with the patient.
We mentioned
Thursday morning
the
statement of some of the
that patience here
is
another term for
fasting.
So fasting and salah the verse starts to
mean
seek aid meaning on your hardships when
you are faced with calamities seek aid
to get you through the difficulties
seek aid in fasting and prayer indeed
Allah is with the patient ones fasting
has an incredible effect on a person's
on a person's hardship and on the way
that they see that said hardship.
When a person fasts,
they prevent themselves from eating or
drinking or having sexual pleasure
during the daylight hours.
When a person breaks his fast,
that hardship is relieved.
It is relieved immediately.
And food has never tasted so good. And
water has never quenched so well one's
thirst. And this is a sped up kind of
microcosm
of the dunya that a person has a
hardship. It's important for a person to
constantly remember that all hardships
are temporary in the life of this world.
All of them. And as soon as the hardship
is relieved, it is as if it never
happened. The only thing that a person
is left with is the lessons they've
learned about themselves and about Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
Also the statement
other scholars of have mentioned that
patience here is as it sounds.
Seek aid in patience
and prayer
in order to be patient during the
difficulties. Now, when we put patience
and prayer together, what does that
really mean? What does that translate
to? What what things do these two acts
of worship, patience and prayer, how do
they complement one another in a way
that make them together appropriate
to help get a person through the
difficulties of a crisis?
And that is that the immediate response
of a person when faced with a hardship
or an undesirable or anything that a
person is striving to get through
something that is undesirable to them.
The first reaction
that a person is to train himself to
have is patience.
It doesn't work every time. And just
because a person doesn't have patience
one moment doesn't mean that they have
no patience. And it doesn't mean that a
person is not patient. Everyone has good
days and bad days. Everyone. And
everyone has times when they stumble and
when they fall. But losing one battle
doesn't mean that a person has lost the
war. If a person exhibits cowardice or
fear during one battle, it doesn't mean
that they are entirely a coward. It just
means that that is an occurrence. That's
not a pattern. These are things that a
shaitan uses to try to convince the
human being, to try to convince the
Muslim that they're not worthy, they're
beyond help, they shouldn't even try.
And sometimes a shaitan puts his words
in the mouths of a of a man's brothers.
Sometimes a shaitan puts his words in
the mouths of other Muslims around his
his target or his victim. The prophet
sallallah.aii alaihi wasallam once was
brought a man
who had drank alcohol and he commanded
that the man be beat and we say beat
it's not you know breaking bones and
drawing blood but it is a kind of you
know a kind of
this is before the regulation of
80 or 40 foggs in the time of.
And so as this was occurring, one of the
companions said
is it's a demeaning term, right?
How often this man is brought for this
same issue. This is not the first time.
This is not the second time with this
same man.
And so the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam said,
"Do not aid a shan against your
brother."
Notice that word there. Do not aid a
shan against your brother.
First of all, any one of us were it not
for the grace of Allah would be in the
position of the lowest amongst us. It is
only Allah's grace that has us where we
are. Number two,
a shan uses other people as we will hear
in another narration in this chapter
uses people around a target of his in
order to disparage, discourage, insult,
put down, etc. This is how a shaitan
operates. If he tries and attempts to
whisper to a person and does not get
through, he will whisper to the next
closest person to him. If he does not
get through, he will whisper to the guy
at the door or whisper to the guy in the
car next next in the next lane. He will
whisper to everyone around that person
to try and turn those around him against
him in order to achieve his goals.
The prophet Sam
said
whomever Allah desires good for he will
turn a people against him. It's a
narration that we will get to later in
the chapter. As we mentioned before,
what types of trees have the most stones
thrown at them? We mentioned this in a
previous talk. What types of trees have
the most stones thrown at them? The ones
with the juiciest fruits. Those are the
ones people are trying to take its
fruits and pillage. Not the ones with
the sour fruits. they don't get
attention.
And so
when we look at the way that Allah
subhanahu wa tala is structured three
chapters of the Quran, surahunus, surah,
surah yuf.
Why are they in that way? Surahunus is a
description of the age-old difference
between the prophets and their enemies.
and all the arguments for polytheism and
all of the arguments and reputations
of Islam against polytheism.
The next chapter hood is about the
prophets and their enemies from amongst
the disbelievers.
Surah yuf is about a man and his
brothers and how even a person's own
people may turn against him. And this is
something that the prophet sallallah.aii
wasallam was given to gear him up and
ready him for the arrival in Medina and
the joining of the hypocrites who would
masquerade as Muslims and prove to be
the most harmful enemy yet.
So the point here that is being made is
that just because a person
gets out of character or out of sorts
once doesn't mean that that is their
character. Do not allow yourself to be
convinced by a shaitan of these things.
A person who is a believer
wants himself to be better. And so he is
hyper sensitive of his shortcomings.
And when he sees a shortcoming in
himself, he starts to lose hope that
Allah could make him better. He starts
to lose hope that he's getting anywhere.
And this is exactly what a shaitan
wants. The most useful tool that a
shaitan has against any human being is
hopelessness. When a person becomes
hopeless, they become dangerous to
themselves and those around them. And so
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala here tells us
seek aid in patience and in prayer.
Meaning that the first response to a
difficulty, the first response to a
crisis, the first response
is to slow everything down and not be
reactive.
Do not just speak. Do not just do the
first impulse that comes into your mind.
Be patient. Seek aid and patience. But
you have a force inside of you and you
can't just stuff that force down all the
time. It will eventually come out if you
just repress
that force inside of you. Whether it's a
force of anger or a force of creativity
or a force of autonomy or independence
or a force of whatever forces that you
have inside of you, if you just try to
stuff it away and wall it, eventually
that pressure will build up and it will
explode out just water.
Allah tells us this in his book
that the powers and energies inside of a
human being, right? The forces inside
the human being, the force of
creativity, the force of independence,
the force of autonomy, the force of
the force of love and lust or
pleasure. these forces that are innately
inside of the human being intrinsically.
If you it's a it's a river
that is running. If you try to just stop
that river with a wall and build a wall
to stop that river, not one drop gets
by, it will eventually break down that
wall and destroy the city beneath. It
will be worse than it was before you
started. The only solution to such
energy is to redirect it.
That redirecting
of force is what allows a person to be
able to take those things which are
seemingly bad about himself and turn
them into a force to be used for good.
This is why Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
didn't prohibit
intimacy between a man and woman
entirely. No, there is a type of
intimacy. However, a man is allowed to
get married. He's encouraged to get
married, etc. There is an outlet for
this force. So, a person to just be
patient immediately,
that's not enough. That's an immediate
that's a band-aid. That's to get you to
the hospital. But you need to work out
and redirect that force. What do you
redirect that force with? You seek
instruction in the Quran. Which is why
Allah then mentions prayer.
So you are patient in the immediate and
then you use prayer and you contemplate
the Quran
and you meditate on the Quran and you
seek wisdom from Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala through the Quran which is most
prominently recited during prayer and
now you find the solutions of how to
redirect those energies
and this is what the companions
did. We know the narration of a man who
would do the acts of paradise until he
is one arm's length away from paradise
and then decree comes into play and at
the very end he starts to do the acts of
the people of the hellfire and enters
it. Why? Why does that happen?
Well, one of the reasons, not the only
reason, but one of the reasons is
repression of energy that has not been
redirected.
It has not been worked out. And I'm not
talking about going to therapy to work
it out. These are actions and acts of
the heart. They can only be solved by
the Quran and the sunnah of the prophet
sallall.aii.
and
[Silence]
subhanalam.
and a Vienna Muhammad.